I am Todd Howard here at Bethesda game
studios you might know me from games
like Skyrim The Fallout series and now
Starfield and I'm here to talk to wired
about some of the games that we've
[Music]
made what people don't know about this
game is one of the first full 3d
Shooters where you look at controls
today with mouse look controls and using
wsad this is the first PC game to ever
do it I had just started at Bethesda
this is in the mid90s team sizes were
small talking to like 10 people 12
people tops everybody had to do a lot of
different things so I did a bit of
programming I was producing I did level
design I became the sound effects
Guy what's fun with this is the old
manual that came with the game and uh
there's a sketch in the back there's a
lot of cool artwork here and one of our
concept artists did a sketch of the core
team here positioned as if we were the
uh resistance in The Terminator world
and there's me in the back and I
remember David plunket here the artist
who drew it just said Todd I gave you
the biggest
gun whenever you're on a team even if
it's four people or 400 people learning
how to use everybody's skills and work
together is you know what gets you the
best game so you know a couple of these
games starting with Terminator is the
beginnings for me at Bethesda and
there's a couple of different phases and
chapters in terms of the games we made
the platforms that we're on and how
everybody worked
[Music]
together Daggerfall is a game where so
much of it is a giant procedural world
where we're relying on the computer to
generate all of the content and put the
individual things that we had built kind
of in smart places around the world
think about 3D today that work is being
done by gpus here it's all done in the
CPU how we built the world is we have a
height map where you get a bunch of
vertices at a you know certain period
and then you're building a height map
for the landscape and then instancing
building 3D objects that get replicated
over and over on that height map and
believe it or not it's how we build
games today it also pushes for us as we
do role playing games what kind of
character that you're going to create so
daggerfall's character system really is
this jump up in terms of defining
yourself what are the advantages of your
character what are the disadvantages of
your character and brings in for the
first time the Elder Scroll skill system
that so many people uh know now from
games like Skyrim and this game had a
lot of success really brought the Elder
scrs to a new
[Music]
audience Red Guard is the first game
that I was the main project leader on
didn't do that well it's the last kind
of Doss based PC game that we made it
might be one of the last dos games it's
right when 3D acceleration starts coming
out really didn't hit a technology
window or or a game G play style it it's
listed as an adventure game but it's a
true genre mashup it has some Adventure
game elements it has action game
elements it has some role playing
elements I guess you could say at that
time we started making a lot of games
instead of focusing and none of them
turned out really really great and the
company was in a really difficult
position financially and I did feel
responsible and I kind of stepped back
from it and said it's a really good game
where did it not resonate what's the
take away and it was just too
conservative we made a very very small
game I think it's well-crafted but we
weren't as ambitious as we could have
been and not what our audience we had
had at the time from Daggerfall and
Arena really wanted from us when it came
to the Elder Scrolls the company's
struggling we probably have one more
shot if we're going to stay in business
so let's go all
in
the company was kind of sold to zenmax
Media a new company and reformed around
that the decision came down we're going
to have one team it's going to be under
Todd and we're going to do morind we
aimed very high we were very very
ambitious to bring back the Elder
Scrolls with a core team that we had had
but taking the learnings from a game
like redard where we are handb building
a world but now we're doing it on a
larger scale compared to the the games
people know today it's actually still
very very small it's very very detailed
the other big thing that comes with
mowind we finally took it to console so
if we go back to the year 2000 Microsoft
is thinking about creating the Xbox and
technically was great for us right it's
a very PC styled console has a hard
drive so many things that we would be
looking for in a console and the big
question was how do we you know
translate the controls and all of those
things fortunately uh we are all here
today uh because this game was a huge
success I was stunned obviously it did
well on the PC but on Xbox at the time
it became the second bestselling game
behind
[Music]
Halo instead of coming out with a quick
sequel to morrowwind why don't we take
four years and really go ambitious again
for the next console with Hardware that
doesn't exist team size now is getting
up to around 60 70 people and this is a
game where the core group from Morin was
still here we could build on that and be
ambitious we changed the technology
hugely again getting into pixel shaders
we having to guess on Hardware so
whenever you're doing technology in your
own side of masses of amounts of content
and Art and Design and then you have a
moving Hardware Target it's the most
difficult game development or any type
of exercise that you could do as it
comes to tech there was a moment we were
making the game with Xbox where that
console didn't have as much memory as we
wanted and when they finally called us
and told us that they were doubling the
memory on the console they were shipping
we threw a party here and I have never
seen programmers look so happy in my
entire life this was a game
that for many reasons it vaed us to an
audience we had never expected
uh to see on the PC and the Xbox comes
out later on PlayStation and it really
starts this other era of games for us
the 360
[Music]
era we were asked what else does the
team want to do what do you want to do
Todd it' be good to have more than one
franchise or one game every four to five
years at the top of our list was Fallout
it was a series that we had loved that
had come out a while ago and we were
able to get the license this game comes
out I believe about 2 and 1 half years
only after Oblivion uses a very similar
technology base that we have built it's
our second game on the Xbox 360 one of
the things that happens with games is
knowing your tools knowing the level of
technology and getting your whole team
used to working with that pays big
dividends is also really special because
we're picking up a franchise that we
hadn't worked in before it's very new
for us it's very exciting but how is it
going to resonate when we translate
basically somebody else's work the way
we would do it or the style of game that
we enjoyed best and this game was even
more popular than Oblivion some of that
audience came with us and it also found
an all new audience because yes there's
post-apocalyptic things in you know
movies and literature and games
obviously but really there's nothing
like Fallout it's the world before the
bombs
fall this world where the view of the
new nuclear future is this Utopia that
then gets destroyed and it also has my
favorite beginning of a game this idea
that when you leave the Vault you would
spent your whole life there and how do
you make the player feel that way so us
jumping through this Montage of these
periods of your life I think it's on
your first birthday in the game when
you're a baby and you're able to walk
around you press the button and the baby
says D that's actually my son on his
first birthday that I recorded uh saying
that back to me so very special game for
me and that sits right with
Oblivion well I think the one we're best
known for is Skyrim now the team is
grown now we're about a 100 people and
you're looking at a team That Grew From
morind to Oblivion to Fallout 3 and then
to Skyrim we were really firing on all
cylinders in Skyrim and it shows we also
started pushing the modding Community
modding is when you modify a game you
take it you change something people want
to create their own Adventures or
artwork or anything our games allow it
we're huge fans of it it's kind of how I
started back on the Apple 2 changing
other games it's still a complicated
roleplaying game but the number of
people who had never played a game like
ours or some people not even any video
game they came to
Skyrim so that right there is kind of
that 360 era for us with our role
playing games where they find an
audience that we never ever expected to
find a level of popularity and us here
learning how to make these games the
teams about 110 or so after Skyrim and
we set our sights on the next
[Music]
Fallout Skyrim is the first creation
engine game where we had re done a lot
of the technology that then feeds into
Fallout 4 new scripting system how we're
handling all of the NPCs and the AI the
era of Xbox one right where the
technology level jumps up again and we
had a very very Dynamic world with this
game if you look back in morind we have
NPCs that feel believable for that era
but they're pretty much standing around
they're signposts as we go into Oblivion
we push that the NPCs could wander
around they had day night schedules they
went to bed you could poison them by
stealing all the food and then just
putting poison apples around they would
decide to eat that Fallout 4 it does
feel like a good action game in your
hands but it has those RPG systems
everything can be used for crafting or
used in some respect so everything you
pick up has these base components build
your own settlements modify your guns
modifier power armor minute to minute I
think Fallout 4 is a huge success for us
for just how a game feels in your hands
so we have Fallout 4 and then really an
offshoot of Fallout 4 that is
multiplayer every game we do everyone
asks us to do multiplayer we usually
decide obviously not to with Fallout 4
we had gotten inspired by these online
survival games a lot of us were playing
said well if we ever did multiplayer for
Fallout that's how we would do it you
know borrows a lot of systems from
Fallout 4 it's the first game really
where we do that where you can see
things from the previous game almost
directly in it you know it's a brand new
type of game and I think it's people
know we struggled and despite its issues
we had a lot of successes we built our
own online platform from scratch sold
really well we had a core audience
playing the game despite its problems
who were telling us we love this please
fix it we join with our community in
having that communication about what
would make the game better how do we go
about about it and us here learning how
to get in a Cadence and continue to
update a game put our heads down do the
hard work and today five years later it
is one of our most played games now a
very big success for us both in terms of
what is doing for players but also it
made us much much better developers
going through a difficult
process
this is an all new experience the most
ambitious game that we've made and the
scale of it dwarfs everything that we
had done so far for a long time we
wanted to do a space game something that
that I've wanted to do for a long time
and something new outside of Fallout
Elder Scrolls an IP that hasn't existed
so we did our first new IP in almost 30
years started development right after
Fallout 4 we knew we were going to redo
the bulk of our technology it borrows so
much of what we've done in previous
games from the procedural generation in
games like Daggerfall we redid the the
base engine that's the whole game Loop
when people talk engine they're talking
about what is the inner core Loop of the
game and how all parts talk not just the
renderer most people see engine they
think graphics render that's just one
part so we redid the graphics renderer
we had a whole bunch of new AI new
animation system we have different
system just for crowds new system for
visual effects and so much of it was new
this project obviously took us a while
and a number of things also happened
during this time we're jumping up in
Hardware into the series X and S on on
Xbox the pandemic happens obviously
affected everybody in the world and we
became fully part of Xbox as as part of
them now with this game you know each of
them on their own create a challenge all
of those things together
uh made this one a challenge but one
that was really really thrilling for all
of us here and if you see the original
pitch of Starfield go back 10 years ago
the tone the way the game feels really
really sticks to
it look what I made here after Red Guard
the company changes and now we're part
of zenax we almost had to like reset
ourselves and who we were coming into
mowind and then we build off that these
share a very similar technology base in
the same way these share technology base
and now this does if we meet again
there'll be an Elder Scrolls six here
you're talking to me but there's 450
people here and we still have people
that work on 76 and a team there and
doing updates for these games about 250
on Starfield these only exist because of
all of those people and us working
together it's why the games are so big
it's why there's so many moving parts
and so many interesting things that
people will find is that comes from
everybody here and all of them putting
something special of themselves into it
you know seeing it visually even though
they're obviously digital the boxes make
it tangible these are these things they
have kind of their own
personalities and I'm going back and
picturing the faces of the people here
that that I've made them with there have
been so many people that have been on
the journey with us here and can't wait
to continue it
[Music]
together